so this is what happens when a 52 year  old decides to attack  uh and go at a guy in jake paul who  literally  literally  has  the youtube social media world by the  [ __ ] balls  so dana's video dana's video is it's  like you know if my dad facetime they're  like i don't need to see up your nose so  it's like a bad lighting he's clearly  like in his mansion whatever it's just  bad lighting  he and he doesn't address anything that  jake asks for right so it's like he's  kind of rambling a little bit  and then jake goes he's off seeing saint  barts of partying for new year's and  someone tells him dan [ __ ] is what he  ha he shoots this video sends it to his  team who all they do is make content and  cut and create  and  literally just  directs dana white in this because he's  using graphics and references and edits  him saying i use cocaine it's like this  is a 10-6 round for jake paul man easily  easily